on the Indonesian island of sulawesi
hundreds of military personnel from 36
countries gather for a week of
non-combat drills this is to strengthen
the cooperation which has already been
well established whoever's here we
warmly welcome them they can enjoy the
stability and security of Indonesia
navies of the U.S China Russia Australia
France and Japan are among those
participating
it's the fourth time Indonesia has
hosted this exercise which focuses on
disaster relief and humanitarian
operations the Indonesian Navy says it's
a chance to promote Maritime cooperation
in the region
the exercises opened with a fleet review
of vessels from most of the
participating countries
this Etsy exercise is going to support
an Etsy search and rescue event where
all the countries are going to work on
locating and recovering a simulated
victim
this is happening at a time of
heightened attention since Russia's
invasion of Ukraine but also an
increasingly strained U.S China
relationship
they also bring together other countries
with turbulent relations including India
and Pakistan
experts say disaster relief training is
a straightforward way for militaries to
work together it isn't focused on
warfighting it is what we call a
operation other than War so in that
sense it showcases the things that
militaries can do and it also allows
militaries to interface with each other
to communicate with each other Indonesia
describes its foreign policy as free and
active
experts say the world's fourth most
populous nation is increasingly
positioning itself as a neutral link for
the region
the Asia Pacific has been a hub of
military activity in recent months
with both the U.S and China ramping up
military diplomacy and engaging in more
frequent exercises in the region and a
contest for influence
this week's drills in Indonesia provide
a rare chance to work together rather
than compete against one another
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera makassar
Indonesia